الاوساط الروسيه منشغله هذه الايام
بالخلاف المعلن بين الجيش الروسي ومجموعه
فاجنر اخر التصريحات مطالبه قائد فاجنر
بالضغط الشعبي على مؤسسه الجيش لتزويد
مقاتله في بخموت بالذخيره الدعوه تحمل
اتهامات مبطنه لوزير الدفاع بتعمد تعطيل
وصول الذخيره والسلاح الى جبهات القتال
مراقبون يرون ان جدوى الانقسام يغذيها
تعطل حسم المعارك في باخموت وبعضهم يرى
انها محاوله من قائد فاجنر لتبرير عدم حسم
معركه باخموت بالقاء اللوم على الجيش في
موقف ممثل لقائد الشيشان الذي حمل قاده في
الجيش الروسي الاخفاق فيليمان وزير الدفاع
الروسي ما يزال يلتزم الصمت تجاه اتهامات
فاغنر لكن الجيش تعرض لتغيرات كثيره لقاده
المعارك خلال العام الاول من الحرب في
اوكرانيا الصراع بين الجيش الروسي وفاغنير
يشير الى حاله من الانقسام ستكون لها
ارتدادات مع استمرار المعارك وهو الامر
الذي دفع بالرئيس الروسي الى توعد من
وصفهم بالخونه داخل روسيا بالعقاب